the opening scene features a
veterinarian named Nick who is examining
a client's dog he suddenly receives a
call from his old friend Lou but chooses
to ignore it meanwhile the client
recognizes Nick as a band singer from
the early 80s so he makes a sarcastic
remark about his current profession in
response Nick throws away the dog's
waist causing the client to feel sick on
the other hand we are introduced to
another one of Nick and Lou's friends
named Adam Upon returning home from work
Adam discovers that his girlfriend has
taken several belongings from his house
before leaving him his nephew Jacob who
is obsessed with video games resides in
the basement Adam suggests that Jacob
move in with his mother but the teenager
reveals that she has already fled the
country with her new partner elsewhere
Lou carelessly drives his car into a
garage while singing loudly and air
drumming he then steps on the
accelerator causing smoke to fill the
garage in the next scene Lewis rushed to
the hospital due to carbon monoxide
poisoning since he has no family to care
for him the hospital Administration
contacts Nick and Adam although the
doctor suspects that Lou attempted to
commit the unthinkable he denies it he
says if he was going to do that there's
only one way to go shotgun to the dick
afterwards Nick and Adam visit the
hospital room and find a loose sleeping
in a hushed voice they whisper to each
other about the possible reasons for
their friend's tragic attempt Lou Who is
awake this whole time throws a pillow at
them and mentions that he ended up in
this state because they didn't answer
his calls in an effort to lift his
spirits Nick and Adam invite Lou to the
Kodiak Valley Ski Resort a place which
they used to visit frequently in the
past they also promised to cover his
expenses knowing that he is severely
debt ridden the following day the three
friends along with Jacob embark on a
journey to the Kodiak Valley Ski Resort
after several hours of driving they
finally arrive at the destination but
they find that the place is just a mere
reflection of the town they used to know
upon checking in at the hotel they are
greeted by an Irate Bellman with one cut
arm named Phil who pulls their luggage
later Jacob draws their attention to a
hot tub outside their room but they find
a dead raccoon inside it Nick reminisces
about how they had a great night in this
same room in the past as they talk the
balcony door suddenly opens and the hot
tub illuminates it has miraculously
become clean and tidy the four of them
jump into the tub with excitement and
enjoy the night to the fullest in the
midst of their fun though they
inadvertently spill an illegal Russian
energy drink named Chernobyl onto the
hot tub controls the next day they wake
up in the hot tub and Lou immediately
vomits on a squirrel after this they go
skiing and try to reenact their college
days but Lou accidentally collides with
the other two causing them to Tumble off
a cliff thankfully they all survived the
fall without any injuries however the
group soon starts to notice that
something is amiss with their current
surroundings they begin to realize that
the restaurant they are in is filled
with pop culture items from the 80s and
all the people are dressed in retro
clothing perplexed the group returns to
their room to try and make sense of the
situation however their confusion is
compounded when they encounter Phil who
has both his arms intact they then and
head back to the hot tub and after a bit
of staring Jacob deduces that they must
have been transported Back In Time by
some sort of Hot Tub Time Machine in the
bathroom they are shocked to see their
younger selves in the mirror they wonder
how Jacob is present when he shouldn't
be born yet while the group argue about
their situation A mysterious repairman
appears and warns them not to change
anything as it may alter history as the
group comes to terms with a drastic
change they realize some unpleasant
events from their past Adam went through
a painful breakup with his first
girlfriend and was stabbed in the eye
with a fork his sister Kelly had Jacob
with an unknown father Lou was beaten by
the ski patrol bully named Blaine and
none of his friends came to his Aid
finally Nick's band's performance and a
disastrously at an open mic contest the
four are deeply concerned about the
potential ramifications of altering the
past in any way to minimize the risk of
the butterfly effect they come up with a
plan to recreate their past experiences
specifically Adam needs to go through
the painful breakup with his girlfriend
Jenny and gets stabbed in the with a
fork Lou has to pick a fight with the
ski patrol bully Nick must perform with
his band at an open mic event and also
make out with a fan girl Nick is
definitely getting the best deal here
later as they are getting ready to carry
out their plans they run into Kelly who
is Adam's sister and Jacob's mother she
explains that she is looking forward to
making out with a random guy tonight
this creeps out our future son so the
group quickly departs after this they
continue with their plan Adam goes to
Jenny's room to break up with her but
she seems interested in rekindling their
relationship at the same time he recalls
how Jenny stabbed him after breaking up
with her afraid of the outcome he urges
her to go with him to the concert
instead meanwhile Lou gets into a fight
with Blaine but ends up getting beaten
up and having his bags stolen as he sits
nursing his wounds a woman approaches
him and offers to take care of him Lou
agrees but Jacob tries to send her away
as it's not part of their original plan
elsewhere Nick rejoins his band and
makes out with a fan girl reluctantly at
the concert Jenny joins the crowd while
Adam stays behind at the bar woman named
April who is a journalist covering the
event approaches him and starts a
conversation elsewhere we see Jacob and
Lou in the same woman's room where she
starts making out with Lou Jacob decides
to leave but the woman insists that she
wants both of them however before
anything can happen she receives a call
from her mother and while she's away
Jacob angrily leaves the woman returns
shortly after but she refuses to
continue as the younger boy has already
left meanwhile Jacob goes to the concert
and learns that Adam has not broken up
with Jenny yet when asked about it Adam
claims that maybe breaking up with her
was a mistake and now the universe has
given him a chance to correct it the
group later gathers in a living room and
Adam is scolded for not finishing his
task Lou is the angriest one but Jacob
exposes him too by revealing that he
tried to sleep with the woman he wasn't
supposed to enraged Lou declares that if
Adam can change the past he can too this
statement makes Jacob a flicker in and
out of existence so he warns his group
that if they continue to change the past
he may be permanently erased scared that
he will lose his nephew Adam immediately
visits the bar in an attempt to break up
with Jenny however before he has a
chance to speak she hands him a breakup
note herself this enrages Adam as he
realized that Jenny stabbed him in the
past when she wanted the same thing as
well he then reveals how she will get
pregnant with several men in the future
unfortunately Jenny takes this as an
offense so she stabs him with a cocktail
Fork repeating the same event from their
past on the other hand Blaine discovers
some strange items in Lou's bag and
suspects him of being a Russian spy in
the next scene Lou and Nick are at a bar
where a lot of people are watching a
sports game this gives Lou an idea
because he knows the future events he
places large bets on the matches and
wins a lot of money after a while a man
challenges him to a high-stakes bet and
Luke confidently agrees however just as
his prediction is about to come true the
squirrel that he had previously vomited
on intervenes causing him to lose the
game as well as all his money this
proves that even the slightest
alteration of the past can lead to
severe consequences in their room Jacob
discovers Adam drinking and writing
breakup poems out of nowhere the
mysterious repairman appears and informs
them that the hot tub needs more repairs
Jacob tries to gather more information
but when he turns around the man has
vanished again after a while Jacob
leaves to search for his other friends
while asking his uncle to stay in the
room however Adam also heads outside and
starts gazing at the stars soon the
journalists from earlier April joins him
and they have a romantic conversation
she then takes him to a house that she
claims is her friends there they enjoy
some drinks and Adam shares about his
father's tragic death due to E coli
April advises him not to let the
incident ruin his life as they lean in
for a kiss the homeowner arrives
prompting them to flee back at the bar
Lou writes down a list of things he
wants to change for the future while
Nick is lost in his own thoughts he
confesses that his wife Courtney cheated
on him despite the fact that he had
dedicated his life to her as a result he
has now lost his friends and passion for
music however Lou tells him that it is
never too late to ReDiscover oneself
Nick is energized by the statement so he
decides to perform his gig he finally
gets on stage at the Kodiak club and
delivers a stellar performance meanwhile
Jacob returns to the hotel room to find
the repairman there the latter reveals
that the key to their time travel is the
Chernobyl because it has special
chemicals which assist in the time
travel process on the other hand Blaine
thinks Lou is a Russian spy and shares
his theories with his friends one of
them suggests calling the cops but
Blaine insists on handling it themselves
eventually Adam April and Jacob meet up
with Nick at the club where he's
performing outside Lou is left alone to
confront Blaine and his friends Nick's
performance is well received and Adam
congratulates him but just then Jacob
interrupts reminding them of the
importance of finding Chernobyl and
returning to the hot tub when he asks
for Lou they realize that they're late
to defend him against Blaine and the
bullies worried they rush outside and
eventually find him drinking on the roof
Lou accuses his friends of cutting him
out and as he continues to rant he slips
off the roof the others manage to get a
hold of him but due to the slippery
surface even they are on the verge of
fall fortunately Phil arrives just in
time to save them after the incident Lou
reveals that Blaine has his bag
containing the Chernobyl and as a result
the group sets out to find him on their
way Adam runs into April who is now
leaving she invites him to come with her
but Adam feels obligated to help his
friends before departing April hugs him
and Whispers that maybe the universe
will bring them back together in the
future Phil then drives the group to the
ski patrol Lodge where Nick and Adam
goes straight to Blaine's room and
begins searching for Chernobyl however
Nick becomes distracted by a photo of
his wife Courtney unable to control his
emotions he calls Courtney who is only
nine years old and yells at her about
the evils of adultery luckily before he
could reveal anything more Adam and
Jacob managed to take the phone away
from him in the meantime as Lou is
checking another room he is approached
by Kelly they engage in a sarcastic
conversation which surprisingly turns
her on soon after the other group
members enter the room in search of Lou
only to find him in bed with Kelly the
sight infuriates Jacob and he jumps to
stop the Intercourse but soon he appears
this finally reveals that Jacob's father
is none other than Lou since the
teenager interrupted the coitus he was
never born and that's why he disappeared
realizing all of this Adam reluctantly
allows his friend to continue doing his
sister when Lou finally finishes Jacob
reappears hence proving their Theory
later as they exit the room Blaine
confronts them holding the precious
Chernobyl he boldly challenges Lou to
try and take it from him and this time
he finds the courage to tackle Blaine
and beat him up in the midst of the
commotion the other members quickly
retrieved the Chernobyl and they all
rushed back to the Hot Tub Time Machine
before departing philbids them farewell
but as he waves his hand a snow plower
passes by him slicing off his right arm
the group then reaches the hot tub and
activates the vortex Jacob and Nick are
the first to step inside but Lou
suddenly decides to stay behind because
he believes he can make positive changes
in his life Adam tries to convince him
to come along but Lou confesses that his
carbon monoxide poisoning was actually
deliberate and he's afraid he might try
it again if he returns to the present
Lou and 10 tends to use his knowledge of
the future to make profitable
Investments and build a better
relationship with Kelly and Jacob after
hearing this Adam says that he wants to
stay too but Lou pushes him into the hot
tub just as it blasts the group back to
2010 after their wild time travel
Adventure the group returns to their
hotel room and discovers a DVD player
they curiously watch a video and are
amazed to see Lou on a luxurious yacht
revealing that he has used his future
knowledge to become wealthy and has
married Kelly they are also surprised to
see that Phil's arms are still intact he
explains that Blaine and his crew were
able to save his severed arm by quickly
icing it and taking him to a nearby
hospital for reattachment furthermore
they learned that Lou has become a
renowned rock star and is also founded
an internet search engine called loogle
did I write that joke later on Adam
entrance's new home where he is greeted
by his loving wife April Nick is now a
thriving music producer who is happily
married to Courtney a faithful and
supportive partner Courtney shares with
Nick that when she was only nine years
old she received a wrong number phone
call that made her vow to never cheat on
anyone in the end Adam Nick Lou and
Jacob reunite at Lou's Mansion
surrounded by their happy families and
content with their new lives
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching